[Music]
Vapors in a little horn set here A.D
with the Bell
[Music]
Reeves being guarded by CP3 whistle foul
counted
threes
Anthony Davis and Austin Reeves so you
got to pay attention to Davis so
Bismarck biambo can't sell all the way
out with the help
it's part of what they're doing right
now Davis against landale here's Reeves
off the screen
turns and fires
went to initiation School
talk about making plays look at the
footwork
Davis started by landale over to read
his catch and shoot three got it boy
Austin Reed still in a good way right
now one point ball game Sons with
possession
here's TJ Warren
over the pain inside lost it Gabriel up
the Beasley and he is healthy can be a
really nice offensive weapon Reeves
sneeze like it was pregame Chapel what a
move you take the Highline I'm not
trying to talk I'm the Holy Ghost on
this
what a move by Reeves slaloming his way
around the screen
okay ping got dropped but it was a good
screen
tp3 all over Reeves
Beasley for three got another one
Malik Beasley and that's something he
can do an extremely confident coming off
screens and using his action
from downtown
by the Lakers and Russell on the board
staying around the three-point line said
his green floating to the three-point
line he sent one there for Reeves Cross
Court to Brown and Brown laces the three
three here's Davis setting the screen
for Reeves
rolls off of it
Vanderbilt inside twists and gets it to
go
the same exact thing all right and force
them to
dreams on the bounce hits Russell on the
Fly got it
D'Angelo Russell with 15.
they go right back to Davis
World Chase action gives it back to
Reeves and Reeves with the floater you
consider Booker CP3 and Kevin Durant
will be back soon Davis inside the Roman
Lakers one spot out of the playing
tournament Phoenix Suns meanwhile the
number fourth seed in the West Reeves
possession with outstanding execution on
plays this time it was Gabriel finding
Austin River Austin Reeves going back to
back to another Dynamic cut by to like a
wing players must see and the Knight is
capped off by Mississippi taking on
Louisville Haley van lit watching play
as well Intruder knocks down the corner
three
double team comes from Craig
they put the sun's in rotation
Vanderbilt underneath got it to fall
with a good play of Reeves Davis first
take the double team the fake pass
forces shaman
Schroeder out top
dangerous pass to Reeves the lob up top
and Vanderbilt with the flush
the needy tonight Mark bacon plays as
time turns the corner delivers the
on-point pass to Vanderbilt he does the
rest this has been an outstanding
victory for the Los Angeles Lakers
playing for their playing